it's rare for North Korean state media
to report any bad news from within the
country at newspaper stands residents
expressed their anger about the
building's collapse the accident really
makes me feel pain inside in a country
where the good of the people is supposed
to be the priority it's impossible to
imagine that an accident like this could
happen everyone in Pyongyang shares the
sorrow of the victims and the Buried
families were smooth as well as
expressing sympathy some also appear to
call for those responsible to be held to
account you consume does this happen
because they broke the rules and methods
of construction after this accident we
have to make sure it never happens again
by sticking to the proper method of
building he's a little geeky diesel
moving on these are the pictures that
the North Korean people have been
allowed to see they reportedly show the
site of the accident and government
officials apologizing for what has
happened little is known in the outside
world about life in North Korea the
government of dictator Kim jong-un
usually publishes only what it deems
flattering images such as those of
military parades it's unusual for the
regime to allow reports of an accident
still the death toll from the collapse
has not been revealed to the public